- [Charles] Now where is my--
- Pardon?
- Oh, that was taken over in France.
And these are two of my
buddies, and that's me.
Watch it.
Memories are still there.
I live it, I see it.
I was not just a veteran, I was
in the Invasion of Normandy,
in the Invasion of Normandy.
No one knows what war is unless
you have been there in it.
- I was up late one night on my computer,
and I saw this wonderful story about
Charles Adderley, a true American hero.
The people in this
community really wanna help
those in need, especially
those who have given
so much time serving their country
and serving their
community like Charles has.
He was in need of a new A/C system,
there were some mold issues, and so we all
just wanted to do everything
we could to help Charles.
- Alright, Mr. Adderley.
So, this was done this morning by the team.
We got the drywall all patched up.
So, once the flooring's done
we can start bringing in
the cabinets and the
actual kitchen materials.
- Sounds good to me.
- Alright. (laughs)
- Mr. Adderley.
When I looked at him, I
just started thinking about
the possibilities of what it
was like, what he went through.
And once he started talking
I snapped back and listened.
- Try to move me.
(laughs)
- You'll have a fight on your hand, yeah.
- [Travis] These guys came out here,
donated their time, they're professionals.
All of our volunteers
and all of our partners,
everyone has just fallen
in love with Charles
and they wanna do
whatever they can for him.
- People need help.
You know, it could be you one day.
You got businesses willing
to give up material.
You got the firemen, we come off duty.
We wanna come and put the work in.
- One of the issues I see these days,
especially with people
my age, is you don't
interact with people who are your elders.
And I mean, there's so much that
can be learned from them.
I spoke with Charles several times
about the history of Miami.
He is 93 years old.
He provides that glimpse into the past,
and it's just invaluable.
- See the date there?
- What is the definition of hero?
What is it?
You can see all the pictures
in the movie--well that's it,
you're going about your
business you forget.
I've seen it all.
- You ready?
- For him to enlist in the
service and fight for a country
that really didn't at that time, you know,
favor people like he
and I, that says to me
something about an individual.
He inspires so many people
from different walks
to wanna help him because, you know what,
quite frankly, we owe him.
That's how I see it, we owe him.
Somebody like that we have to always
show our gratitude and appreciation.
We can never let that go.
And it's not just one day in November.
- You've got to live in the here and now.
The only reason why we're in this world
is what we're doing right now.
To be there for each other.
That's what I learned from him.
- I am concerned about the moment,
and I know better than
to think about tomorrow.
Oh my god, I can't even handle today.
(laughs)
Each and every one of you
has become a part of my life.
Each and every one of
you is a part of me now.
That's how I feel.
All I can say is thank
each and every one of you.